why do you think
people on the nimitz and in the us
government in general not freak out more
at the incredible thing that you've seen
freak out in a positive way freak out in
the negative way
like what are the russians up to again
or or more
like what is this like so more turmoil
so if you to put a chinese flag on the
side of it or a russian flag on the side
of it and i said yeah it had a big
russian flag on the side of it dude
then it would have got a lot of
attention it would have went high order
yeah right if it was
you don't have to say russia or china
just say if there was another country's
emblem on the side of this thing that we
saw
and said oh it belonged to them then
it's a big deal
so here's what's going on so we're
literally in the middle of workups and
it was a joint workup normally they we
go out for a month go come back do stuff
go out for a month this was a two month
at sea period
where we actually had to beg for them to
let us when the ship pulled in at
thanksgiving so we could run home up to
the central valley have thanksgiving
with our family and then run back down
and do this okay
so you know and i just taken over i had
the squadron for a month
right so i'm a a brand new ceo i'm the
most junior guy
on the as as far as the commanding
officer goes
for time in the navy and actually at the
time i think it was the most junior co
405 command in the navy right so
you go okay so i'm out here i got my
squadron i'm running it i see this thing
you know we catch [ __ ] for it i have a
squadron to run
i have the the the tic tac was over here
and although an extraordinary event
i have 17 aircrew and 300 sailors that
i'm responsible for
right their well-being making sure
they're fed making sure they're happy
they're birthing you know and i'm
working with my master chief and i'm
working with my exo
snap and and we're going through all
this stuff
i don't have a lot of time to worry
about the tic tac
yeah if people need to talk to me so you
got to remember
you got the captain of the ship you got
the airwing commander
and you got the admiral those are the
top three and you got the ceo of the
the princeton who is a major command guy
and that's really your big major command
and then everything else is you got all
the squadrons with your o5 command and
you got the small boys that are out
there which is o5 commands so
in the hierarchy as far as rank and
responsibility of what's going on
i'm pretty much in the top 20 with all
my peers and then i've got obviously
the captain uh and the admiral right and
then he's got some
post-command guys on his staff that we
were friends with i think you're
responsible for a lot of things
yes oh yeah this schedule yeah there's
missions
you have to do a lot get the job done
and there's
no time for silly things that's exactly
right so and we're the
we're the integration you know when when
a battle group deploys especially
when you go to the middle east for what
we were doing the air power is the key
it's we take our airport with us we can
park it anywhere we want and we can do
what we need to do
so we're kind of key players so when you
get the theory that oh all these men in
suits showed up so
the captain of ship never said anything
to me the admiral never sang to and the
people on his staff that i was friends
with never saying to me the other ceos
that i talk to on a daily basis never
said anything to me and no one ever came
and talked to me and i'm the guy that
chased it so
in all the theories and all the
debunkers and all the stories because i
don't know if people think they're gonna
get rich on this because i made a big
donut on this i can tell you what i got
paid for i got paid to go out and spend
21 hours of my day going to la and do a
five-minute talk for someone and i'm
like
and it wasn't for the talk because i'll
talk for free because you're not paying
me
i said i said and then i got paid to go
to the mcminnville fest because they
my wife and i got to go because it was
just look like fun because the whole
town gets involved yeah
and it's the only time i've ever spoken
publicly in front of a large audience
about this because it was just
you know it was fun and i got asked and
jeremy and george napping went the year
before so i went with with bob lazar
so i got to hang out with bob and his
wife and his wife and my wife and
you know we all hung out kind of you
know talking not about ufo stuff but
just getting to know each other as
people
because you know bob's like me the stuff
that he talks about is not the center of
his life if anything it ruined his life
you know he's just a really really smart
guy
that's just like the rest of us trying
to get through life yeah
that's nevertheless i mean that was one
of the sad things reading
uh louis lozando's resignation
note from his uh uh he was the program
director at the
uh a tip program like yeah
one of the sad things is that he's
mentioned that you know people
in government just don't take this
seriously as a threat
like ufos as a threat like you said if
it doesn't have a russian label on it
it's a it's a sad thing to think about
that
that we have such a busy schedule that
the
anomaly it doesn't
is a distraction that we don't want to
deal with and it kind of just
fades into history like literally
it's kind of sad to think that if aliens
showed up
like and uh it just didn't it because
they're not
like when aliens show up they're not
going to
be a thing that's on the schedule and if
they
don't start killing people they just
kind of show up in some very
uh nonchalant peaceful way
briefly people would be like
that's that that's uh i don't have time
for this
that's so sad it's like anywhere in the
world so
you know to go back let's go back way
back
way back in the time machine you know
there were people kind of scattered
around the globe
you know in europe's a perfect example
why does france speak french
and then right next to them spanish you
know spain speaks spanish
and they need to kind of jump over in
germans or german and
the polish people everyone speaks a
different language because if you look
at the way the terrain kind of subdivide
the original
people that were there you know
thousands of years ago
they speak differently right you'd be
like the u.s but see the us is different
we all speak english
because what happened we came over and
we started on the east coast
and we migrated west we won't get into
the you know what happened and
you know because the native americans
all spoke different languages yeah
you know it's that same type of thing so
but anytime we have a tendency to show
up
you're you're actually you think about
you're an alien if i go to a different
area if i just
you know go back 500 years where you
know or a thousand years where travel we
weren't traveling across oceans at the
time we were well we don't think we were
the vikings probably were
um because we had limited you know we
had to have supplies and the boats
weren't as big we had to build them by
hand we didn't have power tools and all
that stuff so you know
if you show up someplace like when the
conquistadors from spain came over into
south america and you've got
you know the natives you're actually an
alien
you know and then you look at what
typically happens when aliens show up
in in a human alien world you know and
when i say alien i mean you are not from
that area
the other we
we take what we want and that's what
happened i mean we literally
defuncted civilizations because that's
how we are
you know humans are we're an interesting
group
so you go now what what if something is
from someplace else just let's just
let's just go off the grid and go ah
let's say there are little green men
yeah what are their intents guys lou
asked me this when we were
talking to louisana and he said what do
you think they were here for us i don't
know
he goes what i go hello they were
observing they'd come down they'd hang
out he goes
what if they were prepping the
battlefield what if they were observing
to figure out what we do
and you go that's interesting the other
theory is maybe there's a more advanced
civilization out here and they just
check in on us
because the threat to an advanced
civilization is when a civilization
that's inferior to them
actually develops enough and fast enough
to become equal or above
because now these they become the
threatened type so you watch us grow
until we start getting too much you know
it's kind of like you go well because
they always have a tendency to hang out
around nuclear
right and you go well you know they're
if this is an advanced civilization i'm
gonna go science fiction kind of comical
they come down and watch us and go look
at the
the the crazy upright monkeys now have
developed the atom bomb let's hope they
don't destroy themselves yeah if i was
an alien civilization i would start
paying attention with the atom bomb
that's why the
i mean there's certainly an uptick of uh
what is it ufo sightings since
since the nuclear since the nuclear era
yeah
that's you go hmm
you